hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2017 spanish drama movie with an unusual
plot called skins
the movie starts with a woman lying in
her bed
her name is samantha
she has an anus for a mouth and a mouth
for an anus
usually she lives lonely because she has
an abnormality with her mouth
later she decides to go to a restaurant
without a face covering to express
herself
there the waitress laughs at her when
she wants to order food
inside her feelings she feels very sad
because she also wants to have a normal
mouth
earlier she uploaded a photo of herself
on instagram but instagram decided to
take her picture down because it doesn't
comply with the community guideline
after that the waiter serves her a warm
soup
it turns out that she must use a funnel
to eat
she puts the end of the funnel into her
mouth which is located where her anus is
supposed to be
she pours the soup into the funnel to
quell her hunger when she wants to go
home she is suddenly approached by two
bullies who have strange hairstyles
they start insulting her because of the
abnormality on her face
fortunately she is able to get into her
car and leave the bullies behind
halfway through she runs over someone
that she didn't even see
the scene moves into a teenager named
christian
he has developed body integrity identity
disorder due to his fantasies about his
father who left him at birth the only
thing he knows about his father is that
he has a mermaid tattoo
actually he has a normal body but
because of his fantasies about the
mermaid he does not believe that his
legs belong to him and he wants to
become a merman in the real life
he often spends his time in a wheelchair
so he doesn't have to use his legs as a
result his mother brings him to a
therapist to talk about his condition
during the session he gets in a heated
argument with his mother
she pulls him off the wheelchair so that
he is bleeding
she then pulls his pants off in front of
the therapist revealing a bunch of scars
and wounds
turns out that he often mutilates his
legs with a razor blade all this time
feeling humiliated he pulls his pants up
and he runs away from that place
he is so frustrated to get rid of his
legs but he finally gets an idea soon he
decides to lay down on the road and let
a random passing car run over his legs
obviously from this time it can be seen
that the person who runs over his leg
was samantha because of it he looks up
at samantha and he smiles at her
samantha is obviously shocked about the
incident
this is the first time that christian
feels free and also the last time to
live as he ends up dying from these
injuries furthermore samantha who
accidentally killed christian feels
guilty when she gets home she even
ignores her father's question and she
chooses to reflect in her room on her
birthday she celebrates with her father
because only her father accepts her
condition
her father initially brings her a
birthday cake and in the end she blows
the candles lit with her butthole while
they are eating they have the television
on and they see in the news that a
teenager was hit by a car and person
just drove away her father expresses
that it's truly disgusting that some
people would do such a horrible thing as
he unknowingly hurts samantha's feelings
he then gives samantha a unicorn mask
for her birthday present in order to
hide her abnormal face
meanwhile samantha who is disappointed
with the gift decides to leave her house
later she is cornered again by the
previous bullies and they want to rape
her immediately
samantha responds with a bite to the
man's genitals until he is in pain and
again she manages to run away feeling
like she is at the end of her hope and
she has no reason to live she heads to a
bridge
just as he is about to jump she suddenly
passes out in another scene there is a
normal man ernesto who's masturbating
using his girlfriend's photo his
girlfriend is also a deformed girl
shortly after his mother walks into the
room and sees what he's doing currently
knowing this she immediately has a panic
attack and she says that she's
disappointed with him because he loves a
woman with physical disabilities
as a result he's kicked out from the
house
then he decides to live together with
his girlfriend anna unfortunately she is
currently having an affair with another
guy named guillermo who is a burn victim
it shows them having a good time
together and anna just wants to find
someone who loves her for the way she is
it seems like guillermo is just settling
for her because he's a burn victim and
ernesto is dating anna because he has a
strange fetish for deformed people
at the end guillermo asks her to
immediately cut ties with ernesto and
apparently she agrees with that
soon she invites ernesto to have dinner
together there ernesto tells her that he
was kicked out from his house because of
his fetish of liking deformed girls
thus he confesses to anna that he loves
her physical disabilities which only
makes her angry and she is even more
convinced to break up with him they
finally break up and anna gives him some
money so he can live on the streets
feeling depressed ernesto intends to end
his life
however he is distracted by the ringing
of a nearby phone turns out it is
samantha's cell phone that is being
called by her father ernesto then takes
the cell phone and accidentally see
samantha's face
samantha wakes up begging him not to
hurt her
obviously he doesn't want to hurt her
because he likes her physical
disabilities instead he picks up the
call so he can take samantha home
arriving at samantha's house her father
thanks him for taking her home
meanwhile samantha who's lying on the
couch is suddenly relieved after hearing
the news about christian's death
according to the police he actually
wanted to end his own life
on the other hand samantha ends up
falling in love with ernesto for his
kindness and vice versa
strangely they are kissing each other
and finally find their respective
happiness at the end of the movie
christian is now happy because he
finally lives as a merman in the
afterlife
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching